what would I do without you you'll
always have me congratulations you guys
did it there's a lot looking there's a
lot of pressure on a movie like this
when it's so big number one like number
two everyone loves it
yes so he's not feel any pressure I
think I'm too much like my character now
that I was like of course we're gonna
nail it it's the same team like you had
to say where are the people that you
want to make frozen to it would be these
exact Hebrides no better people for it
and they did it once logic and data
would tell us they're the best ones if
you do do it again
no it's fabulous and the music is so
great and you guys are so fabulous and
now we are getting dual stars on the
Walk of Fame yes we are we're a dual
sounds like we're gonna get out there
we're like so and we're gonna sorta
fight yeah no it is magical it is
actually a cool way to do that it is
well it's also because we couldn't
really have accomplished this separately
you know so yeah and we have this that
we'll share for the rest of our lives
together we had it before we're being
given stars but it's nice to know that
people are gonna walk on top of the I
told Adina I'm gonna go first to put
bubble gum on mine I'm gonna chew big do
you feel like is this another notch in
the I made it like I'm doing the right
thing in my life rocks would you care
any more
I mean we care that we care about this
we care about frozen we care about how
it's perceived if we're old enough to
realize that it's about enjoying the
process and loving the people you work
with that that's the most important not
being as a result oriented about it so I
think that but I think yeah sometimes
you look into your life we're in this
big epic iconic Disney movie and we're
bad but I think it also like wouldn't
people are saying like oh my gosh it's
on track to make a hundred million
dollars I have the first weekend but I
for us I think that telling the story
was so important and they let us really
invest in our characters and I know
and says that but it's real here and
when I hear those numbers
first of all yes we're very very proud
it feels awesome
when I hear those numbers I don't think
about like then the money number I think
about the amount of people that will be
exposed to something that we think is
not only entertaining but a great like
teaching message message yeah
part of this story is about sort of
finding one's purpose guys had good
stories about how older you were and
where you were when you realize that
entertaining people and bringing this
kind of joy to people's lives was your
purpose the first thing that just came
to my mind when you said it cuz I didn't
practice this answer was my grandpa
Nathan five years old he used to say you
just make up stories in the living room
and he'd introduced me I'd be behind the
couch and he say ladies and germs
please welcome to the stage his you know
his own then I come out and then we do
like a musical version of the story that
we made and the look on his face and
he's not with us anymore but like he's
yeah that's I mean that's the first time
I realized that could make somebody
happy
I definitely got like a high off of
making people laugh cuz I was just a
weird kid and I think I was weird and
quirky before I realized that like goofy
was comedy and then that was like a
skill I could hone she was just like
weird he asked for my dinner next to the
dog dish and just eating with my face
cuz I liked my dogs so much more than I
liked everyone else my mom is just like
great she's that's what we got that's me
love her and then I realized that owning
that made people giggle and when you
make someone giggle to me there's no
better feeling in the world it's like a
hit and so I just wanted to do it more
and more and more and I kind of owned
how quirky I could be and tried to use
it wherever possible in this movie
Kristoff is trying to profess his love
for onna and it's not going great
throughout the movie what is the way
that you like your significant others or
people in your life to show you love
what's our love language yeah well like
being protective and supportive like
action okay John said he loves to be
surprised he was like I when someone
throws me a surprise or surprises me
that's how I know I loved so like what's
your
oh I know mine okay access service are
huge for me and my husband literally
said to me this morning because I think
I mean were 13 years in but just gotten
it now yeah and it was kind of recent
but he it's been alarming I he woke up
ten minutes after I did and I was
scrambling to get out of the house and
he said he was like rising out of bed
and he said is there anything I can do
to help you get out of the house on time
and I was like are you trying to make me
a warning right now oh I I think that
like he he books a trip to Africa and
you have asparagus
oh well daddy h2 obviously so I was like
that's a big one I've said service to
other people are also very sexy but acts
of service anywhere you pour your coffee
in hand meal mug as well I'm I'm the I'm
there I don't I don't care how much
money you have or I don't I don't even
it's yeah there's a lot of different
acts of service that yak would quiet
yeah and I like well one he really looks
me straight in the eyes and I find that
extremely sexy and disarming but in a
great way he's the therapist too
so I just feel really seen all the time
I can't get away with anything but I
also feels really seen and very
protected I think as women like that
we're kind of like take hold of our
lives and we do do do and we're very
independent and controlling I'm talking
for myself yeah it's nice when you have
a man in your life that actually is
there and protects you and can like take
care of things once in a while that's
okay even from feminists yeah I'm with
you that when my husband puts the right
socks in the right part of the drawer
I'm like yeah there's no way this is the
last frozen film would you be back I
like to take this opportunity to
announce frozen three four and five
thank you I don't know that Disney knows
that yeah I'd like to formally announce
it and hopefully corner them because we
would love to be that speaking of the
snow and fabulousness a season of love
oh pretty make you cry me I love
Christmas movie I'm actually gonna put
up my Christmas directions decorations
on Sunday real early it's girly Sarah
right after Halloween
but don't you feel like you're always
you put on the radio station and you
have the same songs and they're great
but every now and again you'll get a new
song and it like reignites your passion
and to have this holiday album and ice
and ah there's talk about the things
giving song because there's no right
okay so it's a big it's a lot of big
band jazzy music which I love I used to
sing it when I was younger and I don't
always get the opportunity to it so it's
like lots of brass and strings and it's
got a great vibe but there's an original
song on it called at this table that I
co-wrote with a friend of mine
Jonas Marin and and it's about I feel
like it's my Thanksgiving some we don't
have any Thanksgiving songs but it's the
first song we did before I really even
realize it was gonna make a holiday
album and it's about like inclusivity
and acceptance and people that made me
feel like they're not seen in this world
feeling like they are welcome huh
[Music]
and how do you get ariana grande on an
album like how do you do you just like
you're like hey girl you got one less
problem you're on record ourselves we
know you have a couple friends in common
and you also you're the original Elphaba
and she loves wicked so much so you had
the power you're like it's based like
Oprah calling in English yeah and then
mom splaining yeah I just watched
teenagers I didn't see your sweat is
that wrong you can rock a crappie ah you
know I tried it I thought we could go to
the model do you want to go to the mall
yes we knew it we're so similar I do
[Music]
I tried to tell my kids all the time
that I'm cool and they are not buying it
yeah I mean the whole moms planning with
it was born out of wanting to talk about
motherhood the way I saw it which is
like crazy and dirty and funny and
awesome and so yes we make a lot of
jokes about motherhood and it's one of
my favorite things to me you're so
similar I'm so reluctant I kept talking
about how similar it was to the
teenagers I've learned a lot of valuable
lessons today
[Music]